television is supposed to be
entertainment and it's pretty
deliciously entertaining when TV writers
tried to predict the future sometimes
they don't even mean to but TV shows
have called out world events long before
they've happened here are eerie examples
of some silly little TV shows that
somehow knew what was going to happen
before the rest of us Chris Rock knew OJ
did it before
Oh J did in the first moments of the
very first episode of the Chris Rock
show on HBO Rock aired a sketch about OJ
Simpson Hawking a videotape called
I didn't kill my wife but if I did
here's how I do it it brutally mocked
Simpson acquitted for the murder of his
ex-wife in 1995 but still widely
believed by the public to be guilty
amazingly almost 10 years later Simpson
imitated that sketch in real life with
an almost exact same title when he
penned his book if I did it to promote
it he even taped a TV special called
if I did it here's how it happened
ultimately good taste prevailed and
neither were released
Family Guy predicts Caitlyn Jenner in a
brief throwaway gag in an episode from
2009 baby Stewie Griffin casually tells
Brian the dog the truth about Bruce
Jenner Bruce Jenner is a woman an
elegant beautiful dutch woman that was a
full six years before Janet announced
that she now identifies as a woman and
goes by Caitlyn Jenner as far as we know
she still isn't dutch an x-files spinoff
envisions 9/11 in 2001 two conspiracy
theorist characters from the x-files
known as the lone gunman got their own
short-lived series on the first episode
they uncovered a conspiracy about the
u.s. government planning to crash an
airplane into the World Trade Center
blame it on foreigners and then used a
result in outcry to justify raising the
defense budget apart from real-life
conspiracy theorists who believe the US
government was behind the events of 9/11
it's chilling that a TV show suggested
the possibility of an airplane flying
into the Twin Towers only
months before it actually occurred
quantum leap and the 1996 Super Bowl in
the 1990 of quantum leap Sam quantum
leaped into the body of a high school
football player in keeping with the
football theme of the episode
Sam's holographic advisor al mentions
that he's watching the tail end of the
1996 Super Bowl I've been watching Super
Bowl 30 Oh Sam the Steelers are down by
three one now this is the only game I
care about that's really how Super Bowl
30 in 1996 went down the Pittsburgh
Steelers were in the game against the
Dallas Cowboys and in the fourth quarter
the team really was down by three
oh boy The Simpsons called it
president Trump The Simpsons has a lot
of episodes set in the future but
they're usually just a vehicle to make
jokes about future technology for
example in an episode where Lisa is in
college
robots are common but they catch fire
and melt whenever they feel human
emotion in the same episode Lisa calls
Marge with videophone technology and
whilst we do have Skype and FaceTime
we're still waiting for our melting
robots so take what you will from this
prediction first aired way back in 2000
when Lisa gets elected as president and
you know we've inherited quite a budget
crunch from President Trump it's
possible after all the Simpsons has
correctly predicted the actual outcomes
of elections before America take a good
look at your beloved candidates they're
nothing but hideous space reptiles
thanks for watching subscribe to our
YouTube channel to watch more videos
like the one you just saw and leave us a
comment to let us know which prediction
spooked you the most